at Barnet Hospital the winter pressures
pile onto a Workforce that has already
weathered so many storms
women arriving by ambulance with
breathing difficulties a reminder of
crises past but this year in particular
the security guard on the door of the
children's emergency room tells of a new
pressure
he's here because of record long waits
for treatment that means sometimes
parents take out their frustration on
the staff the anger and frustration is
then towards the nurses and you know and
some of the language that is used is
hurtful and very unkind towards the
nurses
um yeah which makes which is very
upsetting
foreign
like Miriam are presenting because of
fears her son Max has strep when I came
in it was heaving there was nothing
I felt really busy did you go to GP or
just come through we tried to call the
DP and they um they said sending
pictures that's generally pulled back
[Music]
Max was okay but sometimes when this
space becomes standing room only
Children at Risk like 19 month old Jamal
could get missed
he needs urgent attention but mum
Melissa was wary about him coming in
because of the scenes she'd experienced
two weeks earlier because there was just
no space I mean parents were sitting on
the floor with children and every room
every side room the Overflow room it was
awful yeah so it's just Camp six scenes
grandparent Michael had a similar
experience he couldn't come he found the
pressure he just couldn't cope with the
volume of people in it as simple as that
didn't have to start off not enough
and the people were getting annoyed
because
you shouldn't be like this at least down
age
currently the trust is hitting the under
four hour wait Target in 65 percent of
cases just below the national average
staff here didn't vote in enough numbers
to trigger a nursing strike but
hospitals around the country have seen
strikes this week and it adds pressure
elsewhere the NHS doesn't have nearly as
many nurses or doctors as it's supposed
to have that's that's sort of Beyond
debate at the moment and that means our
amazing nurses who are in place are
doing often the work of several people
under immense pressure I think the one
way the public can really help us to
look after them to help them is to
remember when they come to the emergency
department they will face cues they will
face long uncomfortable weights that's
not the fault of the nurses and doctors
looking after you so all we want to do
is deliver high quality care to children
and their families and unfortunately due
to the really high pressures that we are
facing at the moment we're just not able
to provide that and and you know nurses
are feeling frustrated and things
because they're not able to come to work
to do the things that they you know they
want to do you see the strike is
Justified
the trust says staff vacancy levels have
actually Fallen since 2019 but hospitals
rely on Flow depends on the Neurology of
business this is a meeting and an
assessment Ward which is set up
specifically to relieve pressures on a e
and much is about where there's room to
accommodate people
there's a similar meeting two floors up
in geriatrics the issue here is getting
them out
at any one point in time we in this
Hospital have around 60 patients or so
who are elderly often frail but are
medically stable and could leave
hospital but they are um in in hospital
because we are unable to discharge them
in February
that's the equivalent of two wards that
could be freed up if there was more care
in the community and so hospitals have
become a clog Point holding patients who
should be in care
foreign and on the way in some who
should just be getting treatment at home
the Medics here say use NHS online
advice or try to reach your GP but only
come here in an emergency Jason Farrell
Sky News